hey there folks Chris waters here at the
Microsoft showcase at San Diego
comic-con and it's my great pleasure to
be joined by christina chong and mike
colter to the stars of halo nightfall
christina thank you for taking the time
to chat with me
no of course thank you so you guys halo
nightfall I mean it's at comic-con you
sort of been lifting the lid off of it a
little bit more showing folks what it's
all about how's the response been Mike
it's been great everybody's been really
enthusiastic about the trailer they like
what they see and I can understand why
because it's I think we're taking it to
another level we're trying to raise the
bar again for the fans and really get
them invested in this so when they play
the game they're gonna be so much more
invested in that's what we really want I
mean I'm an actor but I'm also
interesting playing a game now that I've
seen the trailer I want to play myself
I'm gonna play and see where this whole
thing goes it's awesome very cool the
game of course halo 5 guardians and the
events of halo nightfall are going to be
leading into that so to give us a taste
of sort of the setting in halo nightfall
christina won't you tell us a little bit
about your character I played a set
whose a said dream soldier and she's
she's kind of very brave courageous and
very loyal loyal soldier and she's kind
of at that point where she's aware that
there's a lot more out there for her in
general and she meets each comes across
the only guys and sees it as an
opportunity to kind of take a step up
and prove that she too with the with the
you know necessary training could become
an elite soldier looking for them like
the only guys of course that elite cadre
we've seen in the Halo universe thus far
Mike tell us about your character well
commander lock is a new new character
that's been introduced to the Halo
universe he's a leader a leader of men
and he's a guy that has a lot of a lot
of positive to positive things that are
going for him but he's still in a stage
of progression the stories an origin
story and this characters being
introduced because he does later on
become a Spartan right now what's so
appealing about his character is that we
get to see him before he's a spar
when he's a soldier but he's not fully
formed so he's in the in the mix he
backs against the wall he's going
through it he's got some things going on
he's trying to protect the people that
he came with it very easy to be
responsible those people and at the same
time he's trying to figure out what is
the next move because when you watch the
film you're gonna see that there's a lot
of things that we're gonna deal with
that we had no you know no idea and
we're in over our heads so that's the
thing about it you want to see people in
a vulnerable situation and I guess
ultimately that's what makes it
appealing the drama of it all we're
gonna be on and on a planet that we've
never seen before and I hope the fans
like what we're gonna go through because
it was really tough to film it and I
think it's gonna be a I think it's gonna
be a big payoff really tough to film it
Christina you're echoing that sentiment
yeah we were in Iceland for half of the
shoot and considering that we were
supposed to be acting as if we were in
on a planet which was 50 degrees Celsius
which is 100 Fahrenheit something like
that there about and we were actually
feeling probably minus 4 degrees almost
freezing like we had to put layers on we
had like two or three layers underneath
our clothes but I you know as you see I
have a vest top for a lot of it so it
was most handy yeah a little bit
challenging yeah so basically we're on a
planet supposed to be very very very hot
but instead in reality it's very very
very cold that's where our keen acting
ability comes in because you will not
notice that we're freezing we we are
very good obviously we have fake sweat
to kind of make it look like you know
and that's water only serving to make
the situation so much more comfortable
for you guys so you know that this
planet it's sort of mysterious but we do
know and we sort of caught a glimpse of
the image behind us that a fragment of
the halo has crashed down to it strange
things are happening and going on there
this is like you're saying sort of an
origin story going to lead into halo 5
so I guess my question for you guys is
you know how's this project
you know so beating connected to this
great sort of lore this established
universe already this videogame that
loved by so many how is it different
than another project you might have
acted on sort of how does that influence
how does it feel - how does it change
the scene well I mean for me I can only
say that you know when it was pitched to
me it was pitched as a film what we did
do is we shot it like a film in the
sense that there was no really no
chapters or there was no episodic
approach to it we shot it with the shot
selections by Sergio who is a wonderful
director he made great shot shot
selections the crew we shot in the same
pace as a film and I feel like the end
product is a film now we will give it to
you in a segmented format but that being
said it's still a film and so I've shot
films and that felt really you know
natural that felt like it was you know
this is this is where I'm at home what
was what was new for me it was shooting
in the armor
I mean shooting in these exotic
locations the characters if you talk
about suspending disbelief but it's an
audience we - as actors it's a little
harder to - you know we have 400 years
in the future everything's different
there's nothing I have in common with
this guy so we will have to submit not
just believing we have to get our minds
wrapped around the POV and what's at
stake the human the human you know
emotion and what and what what's
important and so I think I think when
you see the film I think you'll see that
ultimately you're born it when you boil
it down and I think over the film the
process of film you will see us boiled
down you'll see just ripped away and
you'll see us at our most vulnerable and
I think also believe the human
connections what's gonna bring the fans
in and ultimately once they get
connected again we'll release them back
into the gaming world and we'll see the
emotional connection that's gonna be a
payoff for us you know very cool so
that's and that's one of the things that
I think Halo 4 did very well was sort of
created that emotional connection you
know in the past you're this tall super
soldier and that's fun to play in a
videogame it's a little alienating you
know so I think 343 industries and the
creative teams behind this had done a
great job so far and certainly
optimistic for nightfall Cristina give
us a little something set something that
you think folks are gonna really enjoy
about about the show or about your
character in particular
like Mike touched on I think for me as
I'm I'm not a gamer I'm coming into this
as you know someone who didn't even know
what halo was when I auditioned for it I
think the main thing is the strong
character driven story line and the from
what I hear there's kind of the they
come across some new kind of dangerous
elements and the characters this is new
kind of like you know things coming in
which is gonna be really great for the
Halo fans to see and yet for me it was
it was the amazing locations the action
so much action as well but we were doing
were abseiling rock climbing or maybe
not this guy but I got out of that one I
got out of that one no rock climbing
well that's not the reason let's just be
honest I mean I'm a man of all men I'll
do anything but luckily it was written
so I started a scene I was down already
I was already had I had already gotten
down yeah how convenient Mike wanted to
be there but unfortunately I needed to
do the dialogue at the bottom so I just
you know this is one of those things one
of those things well thank you two so
much for taking the time talked about
halo nightfall certainly a lot of
Secrets in there for Halo fans and I
think sounds like some cool stuff to
discover for us all about the characters
we're gonna see a lot of in halo 5
guardians thank you folks for watching
his more tuned to GameSpot for more from
comic-con